I don't think you understand the mental toll
of being dogpiled on by the entire internet
I don't think you understand the mental toll of being a fat person
on the internet
with a large audience
I don't think you guys understand what it's like to have hundreds
if not thousands of millions of people hating you
like I don't think you guys cannot comprehend what that is like
right so you can have your opinions on whoever have your opinions of
but I need you all to like
understand that the human mind is not meant
to withstand the amount of hatred that can be pushed onto one single
individual person now on the internet
like I
the human mind is genuinely not meant to consume that much hatred about oneself
it just really isn't
so my rule of thumb normally is when a situation is happening
before I contribute to dog piling onto a person and saying things
I've already been said
uh I think about first of all
is that person in a place to be able to understand what I'm saying to them
to be able to take what I'm saying constructively
or is this gonna cause more harm than good
also like what are
what is the context of what is going on
like what is the mental state of this person
like why
what's going on
like I just
oh like
I uh I have been attacked by Ed
Twitter by Taylor Swift
stans by you know
anti fat liberation people on YouTube
libs of TikTok stans
like I have experienced dog piling in a way that many people have not um
and I truly would not wish that experience on my worst enemy
I don't think like I
there are very few people who I think deserve to be treated in that way
I think there are very few actions um
that deserve that type of treatment
and um I don't know
I guess maybe I have too much Grace um
as someone who has first hand experienced the toll that it can take on someone
um all I'm gonna say is maybe
just I don't know
be considerate of that